il est près de 20 heures quand le
véhicule des pompiers évacuent johnattan
d'aval vers l'hôpital de vesoul
l'accusé s'est effondré en plein
interrogatoire je tends pas de lui je
pense sincèrement que le malaise est
enfin prévu devenir blanc blanc
s'écrouler c'était pas du oui c'était
pas du pipeau l'audience a été très
longue
la salle est petite et je pense aussi
qu'émotionnellement la journée a été
très dur des témoignages très fort très
très signifiants et celui de d'isabelle
fouilles au conte pas du tout laissé
indifférent bien évidemment de la tène
d'aval celui de jean-pierre fouilles
aussi a été absolument déterminant dans
la journée et je pense qu'avec la
fatigue la chaleur
johnatan fait trois heures de route par
jour aller retour c'est compliqué il
dort très peu ce qui peut expliquer ce
ce malaise avant de chanceler dans son
box
johnatan d'aval avait répondu
fébrilement aux questions du président
de la cour d'assises pendant une
quarantaine de minutes
l'accusé avait d'abord présenté ses
excuses aux proches de la victime
même si ce sont ses propres mots ce
n'est pas excusable s'excuse une muse a
déjà présenté mais on peut pas les
accepter
à partir du moment où ce n'est qu' il
n'était que mensonges et toutes ses
déclarations noter que mensongères on
peut pas accepter ses excuses
l'interrogatoire de johnatan d'aval doit
reprendre dans la journée
ses explications sont très attendue
notamment par les parties civiles